all right let's see if
we are live well
it is a pleasure to be here i am going
to introduce
the channel of the of the of the century
having hit
100 one tenth of a million subscribers
10 to the fifth
subscribers of an amount that i can only
dream about
at my youthful age of one year into this
podcasting game but i've learned so much
from professor christian reddy who is an
influence on me
and the universe in which i inhabit
always trying to
up my game to be even one logarithm
one logarithmic interval of what of what
chris could do
so i uh i am pleased to announce uh that
we are doing a crisscross a crossover
like
remember when that well you're probably
too young but i remember the facts of
life and different strokes and they
would have a crisscross crossover
episode
so there's a crossover episode of launch
pad astronomy where
our motto is stay curious my friend and
in san diego we say
stay classy my friend and it's a great
pleasure to be here talk about new
observatories talk about some of the
great topics you've been on
and maybe look into a mirror of a
different kind because as i understand
it when you hit a hundred thousand
subscribers
you get a mirrored plaque that you can
turn into a telescope
did you get one yet
you gotta get it out
just california just california yeah
just university of california
san diego yep
nice oh come on you gotta open i gotta
do the unboxing
let's do an unboxing and that'll really
break youtube's algorithm right
oh yeah
yeah it shows it as just fine
i see my um my sound is up
uh interview try saying something there
uh maybe is it a settings thing on your
side because i see
uh
hello everybody on the into the
impossible podcast i hope you can hear
me now
there we go okay i hope i hope you guys
can hear me now
uh we're just waiting got a little bit
of a delay on your side
make sure that uh yes this is actually
live jonathan
um i hope your folks can now we're both
muted
that's not true okay
no sound cannot hear the guest um
it should be working now can uh somebody
brian your sound is choppy as well oh
folks this is an experiment and and
realistically i don't want to
to chew up too much of your time uh
everybody on launchpad can hear me okay
uh um i just want to make sure that we
can get it okay
everybody sebastian you guys all hear it
now good now okay
uh you guys can hear christian christian
give me a count hello
one two three uh pi over two
pi not
how's now it says can hear now okay we
have ken here now
on into the impossible yes anyway
let's keep talking and we'll see oh good
okay
okay we got folks we're good to go we're
back in business sorry everybody hi my
name is christian ready
anyway um uh so brian check your
comments you're coming in a little bit
low
according to your viewers i think you're
coming in now pretty good here yeah pick
it up and i'll make it
nice and loud right
hey look all right lucky lucy hi good to
have you here
we're so glad to have you and roka both
brian and i
are using ecamm live except we just
don't know how to use it well that's all
so well i always say christian it's an
experiment and most of my experiments
fail
exactly and that's how it always works
in science we get things wrong
all the time exactly all right good we
are good to go
now that we're good to go so anyway as i
was saying before brian has done a lot
of
research into the cosmic microwave
background trying to understand
uh you know signals coming from the most
distant parts of the universe
but what's really really interesting is
that brian's stumbled across some
research
where perhaps the background the cosmic
microwave background can be
used to understand potentially discover
something in our
in our comparative local neck of the
woods
using the c and b to find planet nines
how does this work
exactly yeah so i always say uh it's
going to be really fun to watch the
optical astronomers
try to measure the cosmic microwave
background with their large optical
telescopes
because now we are horning in on their
racket we are able
with a high-resolution instrument such
as the that my
colleagues and friends are building on
the simon's observatory our large
aperture telescope
will have a resolution of about about
one arc minute
which doesn't sound that great compared
to say the hubble telescope or
jwst or gaia or something but it will be
sufficient to detect
with the phenomenal sensitivity that we
have
anything that's above absolute zero
gives off heat and we can
detect that because it can't be colder
than the cmb temperature
which is 2.7265 kelvin as all your
listeners know
therefore a planet which could be at 30
kelvin is enormously more energetic
more bright in the thermal microwave
bandwidths that we can see
and therefore something like a kuiper
belt object or a
something even in the inner orc cloud
could be detectable in fact will be
detectable
and that includes such things exotica
like planet nine so on my channel i did
an interview with
my colleague professor dr sigurd nais
who's at
the university of onslow in norway and
he gave a
you know what i call the journal club so
one of my playlists is kind of like
journal clubs i want people to feel the
excitement of being in a
in a university environment with no
tuition in their pajamas
as i always say so um so there's a
journal club episode with him
talking about the prospects for
detecting planet nine
and i also had on constantine batigen
who is an astronomer at caltech
a professor there does planetary science
he's a theorist
so he's not using telescopes but we
talked about the prospects for
the such objects to be detected much the
same way
that the planet neptune was detected by
le verrier essentially predicting based
on the gravitational
influence of some unseen form of dark
matter
i.e a planet that had hitherto been
undetected
so exactly the same types of techniques
are very complicated because it's the
three-body problem it's the infinite
body problem
solving that is notoriously difficult
drove newton mad
and uh you know i'm already a little mad
to begin with but yeah
bring out my fingerprint there we go
don't make me bring out my finger
puppets
um someday you'll have one we'll have
one for christian
so yeah so we're able to detect it we
believe if it has you know a wide
a variety of different parameters that
are expected
from such an object in the in the outer
solar system
so we'll be able to do that and as i say
i'm throwing down the gauntlet to my
friends in the optical astronomy
community
can you measure the cmb at optical
wavelengths that is not
technically impossible i guess
so yeah and anything that gives off heat
is detectable
and a challenge that all astronomers are
facing
but more so in the cmb community is the
problem of these mega constellations
these satellites that are providing
internet coverage to millions perhaps
billions around the world
it'll be great if they were using it to
like beam to our friends in cuba
right now give them some free internet
elon uh
do your cosmic duty but i don't know if
that's happening
but anyway these mega constellations
are above absolute zero therefore they
emit microwave radiation
therefore they can contaminate our
measurements and that's a big challenge
because in the optical
as bad as they are they can be painted
black and like the rolling stones
would advise us but you can't paint on
some coating
that that absorbs and and fails to emit
any microwave such a thing violates the
laws of thermodynamics so it's a big
challenge to us and i know you've
thought a lot about this on launchpad
um what's the latest with this in terms
of the optical astronomy community and
maybe we can
kind of join forces with optical
astronomers and microwave astronomers
yeah i know it's a really uh that's a
very important question i mean obviously
you know ever since
uh spacex really got the ball rolling
with the first ever mega constellation i
mean you know
multi-satellite uh constellations for
communication
goes back to iridium right you know but
that's just a hand
a comparative handful of satellites for
satellite telephones
now we're talking tens of thousands of
satellites uh spacecraft
just from spacex that's not to be
confused with
uh amazon's i believe it's amazon's one
web
uh then or then there's the kuiper
program
then there's uh china wants to do one of
these things
we're talking about a lot of sats out
there
that's a that's a huge problem and and
uh it's not just a problem
for optical but also for radio astronomy
so anyway
when spacex did their first launch
back in uh let's see back in uh 2019 is
when they did their first launch i mean
the american
the astronomical community immediately
took notice and they were like oh man we
got
we have a serious potentially very
serious problem here
and they organized a conference called
satcon1
because i knew they were going to have
to do this more than several times they
just got done this past week they just
wrapped up
satcon 2. okay hey progress we've made
we've had two satellite um satellite
conferences now the thing about this
is that they've got you know
participation not just from the
astronomical community but
actually from the some of the satellite
uh
providers themselves apparently there's
representatives from spacex from amazon
from att
there you know all these folks who
actually do want to get involved because
they're actually not trying to
destroy the night sky they're just
trying to make money
i mean that's really what this is about
that you know but many of them
actually like the night sky as well and
it's quickly become
uh it's not just an issue just in
astronomy but also there's cultures
there's
uh you know the citizens really want to
have the night sky taken away
from them and in some sense it's kind of
like reverberating a little bit to say
oh yeah you know what we're also
you know polluting our skies with with
visible light
what can we do about that okay so what
can they do about that
well it comes down to several different
working groups i mean that's
what that's what scient that's what we
do right we we form committees we form
working groups so we basically try to
tackle like one slice of the problem and
while there weren't any definitive
solutions announced
there's actually going to be a proper
report coming out of september but they
wanted to do a presser
just to kind of put a bow on this week
and
you know what they what they really what
they were encouraged by
i mean i do want to say encourage was
the fact that yeah
providers really are legit concerned as
well they want to do what they can
uh and uh and i'm just looking at my
notes here as i'm talking to you so i'm
gonna go ahead and try to do so
they got to do a few working groups one
is uh you know figuring out how can we
solve this problem because guess what
you're not going to solve the problem by
getting rid of the satellites okay they
are not going away
they are going to make money and at the
end of the day there's nothing we can do
to stop them they've got the money
they've got the power they've got the
lobbying
they're going to make put they're going
to have the sky swarming with satellites
the trick is
can you make them faint enough such that
they will not interfere with
astronomical observations and can you
also make them faint enough so that they
won't even interfere with
just naked eye observations the first
the second problem is actually much
easier to solve right because the human
eye can only see down to basically
on under the best of circumstances down
to about magnitude six
so think about the brightest star that
you see at night and then think about
the faintest star that you could
possibly see at night that's a magnitude
range from very roughly
zero to six you know and it works out to
like a factor of
you know roughly 100 or so in brightness
that's all fine well and good the
problem is that
with faint objects in the sky and guess
what there are a lot of faint objects in
the sky
we are struggling to make observations
to the very faint objects because now
when a spacecraft passes across the
field of view
you're outshining your target by about a
factor of one billion
okay this introduces light into
the image or into the spectra that
completely buries the signal
so what did i say earlier we're not
going to we're not going to get rid of
the satellites we got a software
and hardware our way out of this so the
two things are that okay there needs to
be
a very accurate database put together
something called sat hub is what they're
calling it right now and this would be a
place where
astronomers can go just to find the
latest ephemeris which is basically kind
of like a table if you want to think of
it that way or a computation of like
where
a given spacecraft is going to be over
your location
and when it's going to be there and how
long it's going to be there etc etc
designing your observations around that
right we need software to help us do
that
now if you've got uh so that's the
software that's one of the software
tricks fixes the hardware fix comes in
next because no
the second second i should say this the
second part of the software
fix is what can the software do to help
us in post-production
to help us weed out those crummy signals
and leave us with our data but again
there's only so far you can get with
software fixes right you can't
reinvent data you can't make up data
that's there's no point
in doing science if that's all you can
do so you now need hardware fixtures you
got to have like
auxiliary cameras looking like adjacent
to your telescope
to give you warning when to stop your
exposure when to stop taking data let
the satellite pass and start taking data
again
there's going to have to be an awful lot
of these kinds of
software and hardware fixes yeah um yeah
and and
and this is this is not exactly easy to
do i mean this is something that the
satcom folks have
have certainly recognized this is a
serious challenge
but if they can get providers to work
with them on this it can go a long way
the question is can we get people like
china to work with us on it and things
like that
so yeah many challenges and by the way
uh just as a
a final uh thought on this if you are
dealing with some of the big
huge observatories like the extremely
large telescope the giant magellan
telescope even keck and so forth they
got really narrow fields of view you
know what
they can they can manage or they should
be able to manage it's when you're
dealing with the reuben
survey telescope and the fritz vicki
you know survey uh array and things like
that these wide fields of view
you've got a serious challenge on your
hands and basically the reuben folks are
saying look
forget it there's nothing we can do
about this except
you know stagger our exposures a little
bit and then try to like
you know you know cancel off the
the crummy uh photo bombs by the
satellites as best as we can
so yeah it's gonna be tricky very tricky
what about like the prospect of
advertisers and folks on my channel are
thinking about you know
can you make uh we've seen these images
of you know ibm
drones flying around with the ibm logo
and
so forth what about and i even heard you
know using the moon as a giant billboard
with laser
light shows um as if we didn't have
enough to worry about
um when we're not you know busy
suppressing aliens and so forth
but uh but but tell me like have you
heard anything about that like is this
is
is the sky off limits for for
advertising or is it still it could be
open game for you know amazon prime
you know nothing came of it in today's
press conference uh so i honestly don't
know
if if uh you know celestial advertising
uh is uh is a concern i think right now
this is more like okay what can we do
just from like the night to night sort
of thing but you're right
it it you know companies are are
are allowed to pollute in oceans and
lakes and so forth hey
why not you know why not paint eat at
joe's
you know in oil on top of the on top of
the uh
ocean you know um and set it on fire
like they did yeah exactly light it up
you know uh well obviously they can't do
that right at least
you know they're governed by net you
know
domestic and international laws and
things like that and that's where it's
gonna have to come into there's going to
have to be a lot of international
cooperation as a matter of fact bez was
asking what is the challenge of china
working
on this with us and as far as i know and
does don't put
you know i can only tell you what i
happen to have heard so far because i
wasn't actually at this conference
doesn't seem like china's involved in
the conversation right now
and getting through to them is a bit
tricky
because they don't want to be as
involved in the community
i don't know and i hope i'm wrong i
really do would i would be very glad to
be wrong about that
so um yeah so when you're trying to
seek out you know make observations
you're asking brian originally what got
me off of this rant here was that
you know how do we do this can we join
forces with the radio
uh uh astronomers
yes i mean clearly there's common cause
here right you know uh we have uh
you know fortunately the radio community
is already
has there are bands of the rf spectrum
that are reserved for
astronomy but you know what astronomers
aren't
all of nature does not broadcast in
these very discreet
safe uh you know radio bands nature
broadcasts and all these bands
that's right so you want to be able to
do your science anywhere you need to
they want to be able to broadcast where
they want to you know
so yeah this is definitely leading to
some uh common cause
now let's let's talk about some of the
future observatories that will be
you know some of which will be far
beyond the orbit of these
low earth uh or intermediate earth
orbits so
in particular you've done a lot on your
channel with the jwst
and uh and talking about what it will be
capable of
uh i've had less to say about that so
what's the
current status uh you know is it delayed
you know again
uh month per month day per day uh for a
while it was being delayed you know such
that it would launch by the time my
great-grandkids are
professors um so what's the status of
that instrument
and uh from your perch near our nation's
capital at
towson university oh yeah yeah
washington dc is right down the road you
know
like an hour and a half but anyway um
i don't have any contacts uh in dc on
this but i can i can say though that uh
the news on james webb space telescope
is actually good for once it's
it's uh yeah so there were some recent
delays
announced but honestly folks
they just weren't really the kinds of
delays like we saw i mean we can go back
decades i mean look this thing was
supposed to launch originally in 2007
yeah 2007. okay we're a little bit
behind schedule
you know look they've had to do replans
and refiguring this thing
and so when they said that hey you know
we may have to delay this thing by a
couple of weeks
to me that was like no no big deal but
but why did they have to delay this by a
couple of weeks
yeah okay it's supposed to launch
out of french guyana on a ariane 5
rocket
it's actually a really good launch
system it's
been working great for you know well
over 25 years now
uh it's got the basically the largest
widest launch fairing and that's the key
thing because web has to fit it's a six
and a half meter
telescope and it's a 5.4 meter
fairing so if i've done my math
correctly web shouldn't be able to fit
inside of the fairing
you have to fold it got a folded up
origami style you know and
and cram it in there and it even then
just barely fits
all right no factor they figured out
after a lot of testing and yes and
after a lot of delays they figured out
how to get it to fold itself
up and unfold itself reliably to the
point where they're confident that this
this should work in space
okay good news then
last year on two separate launches there
was this
anomalous vibration uh when the arium5
launches that you know the fairing
splits open
to let the payload escape and all that
kind of stuff and
this thing really rattled like more than
was
supposed to yeah and this got the
engineers very concerned because the web
is a very
fragile spacecraft compared to your
typical comsat right it's a
communication satellite is and i know
i'm oversimplifying but it's it's a big
box it's a big cube
with solar panels on it and some
antennas boom you're done no factor
right
and it can just by by the inherent
nature of its own design
it's able to withstand a little rattle
here and there that's not the problem
webb of course if you've ever seen it
it's this or it's just
it's beautiful but man it's fragile
right so now they're worried about wait
a second we got this anomalous vibration
how do we address that well
it turns out arianespace seems to have
addressed it now i'll believe it when i
see it
and we're supposed to see a launch of
arions5
this month followed by another launch
next month and then
web would launch notionally no earlier
than
october 31st here's the thing
webb's got a ship down to down to french
guyana
right it's got to be integrated onto the
spacecraft it's got to get
ready to go uh arianespace says that yes
double d
yes they said that they have fixed the
fairing pressure issue
like i said we'll believe it when that
happens we're waiting for the
waiting for the flight data to come in
but if we um
uh get a good result then we're going to
launch but that's not going to happen on
october 31st that's almost guaranteed
not to happen on october 31st that will
more than likely have to happen in
november
possibly early december good news web
can launch
any time of the year it's going all the
way out to l2 which is the
the lagrangian point between the sun and
the earth and
it can go out there any time it needs
first occupied by my
namesake my phd advisor's phd advisor
david wilkinson
his uh wmap satellite first one ever to
inhabit
l2 lagrange point there you go man
first one so brian first right yeah
so we've got uh we've got this uh launch
lined up and
even though it can go any time they're
not going to go any time they're going
to their window
ends in early december in other words
they're feeling pretty good they're
going to go
in in 2021 and i am actually cautiously
optimistic that's going to happen
and uh looking at first of all let's
remind our listeners we're doing a
crossover episode
all the power of launch pad astronomy
with the
imagination of into the impossible
so go ahead uh the intelligence of into
the impossible yeah man
and you know the uh number one cause of
of early mortality is
lack of exercising your finger to click
the like button
the subscribe button and uh so please
cross over and click and subscribe
to launchpad astronomy and if you're
listening on
christian's channel he's got my channel
linked there appreciate that we're
trying to
break through to the um to the cube root
of christian's
massive audience which could fill up two
two washington football team stadiums
uh it's great i've been on the show
twice
twice now and this is the first time so
at the very end which we we have only
till the top of the hour
um i'm going to ask you my thrilling
three final questions christian then i
asked nine nobel laureates
three billionaires an astronaut while
she's floating around in space
and uh and i want to also take questions
from the audience so
uh so yeah so before we do that
um you also had a really cool recent
episode if i'm not mistaken
about another um another upcoming
instrument in in astronomy and cosmology
you want to talk about any uh
any other of the great observatories
that you've been featuring lately
and uh well um so right now
the astronomical community is waiting on
uh pins and needles
for the uh what's called a decadal
survey
basically every year the astronomical
community gets together they compile
this great big
survey of what they want to accomplish
scientifically in the next decade
and that in turn leads to
recommendations
good news nasa is required by law to
consider
to consider the decadal survey when
planning out their
uh space telescopes and things like that
the decadal survey gave us hubble the
decadal survey
or decal sort of recommended hubble they
recommended james wood what
recommended roman and now there's four
count
four amazing observatories that would
succeed james webb okay like among other
things like forget the successor to
hubble this would be the successor to
james webb
anyway uh long story short because i do
want to get us to some questions uh
there would be an advanced uh x-ray uh
spacecraft that would take over from
where chandra is leaving off basically
rough think the same size of chandra but
about 100 times the
sensitivity so the chandra deep field
for example which is basically an x-ray
image of a deep
you know long exposure image of the
x-ray sky
took them oh i think like the better
part of a month to complete
well lynx its successor could not
could do the job in a day you know we're
talking a tremendous increase in
sensitivity
there's a habitable exoplanet explorer
which would
fly a star shade ahead 50 000 kilometers
ahead which would block out the light
from a distant star to reveal
the planets going around it and be able
to directly image
those planets that's a very exciting
thing there's also the origins
space telescope which would be a general
purpose infrared
infrared telescope capable of finding
those cool gases and look and probing
very deeply into those
gas clouds where stars are forming and
get the highest resolution image and
spectra
of those forming stars then there's my
favorite then there's the
large ultraviolet optical and infrared
observatory luvoir imagine
a something that looks like the james
webb space telescope with this hexagonal
mirrors but it's like
oh whereas james webb is six and a half
meters yeah this one's going to be
16 meters across like this would be huge
and best of all
it's optical it's it's doesn't have to
have these crazy thermal requirements
that have made
our jane poor james webb takes so long
to develop because
to get that sun shade deployed is such a
a tricky business
so we are waiting to see which ones
i think they need i think they need to
recommend all four but they need to
uh they need to get a they need to get
in there and and uh
make the recommendation that
recommendation is expected
virtually any day now seriously it's
coming soon
so i didn't do some videos about them
and uh
yeah you know i mentioned uh you know
the space the station which is
celebrating its 24
third decade this year and i did an
interview with jessica myer two years
ago a year and a half ago when she was
on
uh the into the impossible channel you
can find that somewhere
around here uh but um but last night i
read a startling statistic
that it's the most expensive uh
thing ever made it cost 150 billion
dollars
the space station which by my
calculation is about 10 lhcs
and someone's asking simon farmers
asking in my chat room how many
ground-based telescopes could we have
built
using the money from jwst utilizing the
newest adaptive optics ground-based
massive telescopes you know we don't do
we need to go to space
so simon's asking questions along those
lines do we are we really you know these
huge projects these overwhelmingly large
government projects nasa pro i mean what
have we gotten from the space station
where do we you know i didn't want i
don't think it would be polite to ask
jessica
while she's floating around in zero g
you know what the heck have you really
gotten for your 100
you know 10 10 uh lhcs but what do you
think about this and then we should take
questions from your audience too
okay science of science it's important
that we do it
well there was a time when somebody
discovered this strange form of long
wavelength radiation uh they didn't know
what it was for what it was doing but
they decided to call it radio and you
know scientists
being scientists went and looked at some
other stuff right and
who knows how much it costs to discover
and and figure out how to manipulate
radio i know it doesn't didn't cost
nearly as much as
the station but you know what uh
somebody figured out that there was
actually a practical use for radio
you know you know and so i don't
i i tend to say yeah i hear you i
totally
understand where you're coming from on
the cost concerns
um you know as an astronomer i could say
that well you know there actually is a
there actually is an x-ray telescope
mounted on board uh the international
station which
has allowed us to make the very first
maps of a neutron star or a pulsar since
it's rotating and
the thing is is like we've always had
this beautiful textbook description of
what a pulsar should be
it's this ultra compact neutron star
that's spinning super fast that's going
to have these magnetic poles going up
the sides and it's going to whip around
like a lighthouse right
now now it's actually funky
it's really funky it's got these
magnetic field hot spots that are
kind of both in the south south southern
polar region
like which is completely wrong right
compared to what we
a pulsar look like so you know
then we have this other larger question
okay fine we can do science with the
station
why then don't we just do it from the
ground and that's simple
on well it's it's a simple answer but a
very difficult implementation
it's a simple answer because there's
only some sciences there's so much
science that you cannot do from the
ground
how many ground-based telescopes could
we have built for the cost of the james
webb
a lot i assure you absolutely there's no
question about that
the thing is is that they could not do
the kinds of science that james webb can
do
the atmosphere obscures our view
of the infrared sky and if we want to
be able to actually see the universe
expanding into the distance
we have to we have to go into the
infrared
at very high resolution and that's
something that we can only do from space
you know what i mean so it's like the
question is like you know should we do
ground-based telescopes or should we do
space-based telescopes in a perfect
world yes we should
both you know but but the but what helps
to make the decisions is what is the
scientific payoff going to be right
these are not monetary investments we're
not going to make money off of this
stuff
what is the scientific pay payoff that's
what drives us
into these decisions of what missions
we're going to fund
so go ahead no no that was yeah i think
you're absolutely right you know i think
the limitations of it you know you have
to draw a line at some point i had an
interview with
dr james beacham who's been on many
documentaries and ted talks and stuff
like that
he works for the lhc and he was on to
talk about putting
a uh a 11 000 kilometer diameter
lunar particle accelerator so a
lunar circular accelerator that you
didn't even give the cost i mean
to give them credit uh but you know you
have to dream big and i pointed out that
in the time since the since um since
lawrence up the road in
berkeley built the first particle
accelerator
you know of any size it was this big it
was 36 centimeters in diameter
and we've gone to 27 kilometers in
diameter which is
you know orders of magnitude more than
going from 27 kilometers
to 11 000 kilometers and so
you know why not think big but of course
you always have to have a good reason
to deploy these funds and i think in the
the struggle for my particle physics
friends is that there is no natural
target
uh for build you know it's bigger is
better but that can apply to anything
you could say that for
you know advertising or weapon systems
or whatever so
it's always good to have a natural
target uh which are few and far between
as you know in most science
in most sciences absolutely
you know uh and and sooner or later
there just has to be a decision made
uh and and and it all comes down to
cost benefit you know what what can we
do um
you know i i've often heard you know oh
well these new
next generation of ground-based
telescopes which i know we haven't
really talked about yet but
they're going to outperform hubble what
do we need a hubble telescope for
again you know it depends
it i always say it basically kind of
comes down to
what problem are you trying to solve are
you trying to
you know observe in a specific
wavelength at what resolution at what
level of sensitivity you know and and
you use the best tool for the job it's
like
any other craft you know you you have to
have
more than one tool in the toolbelt if we
could throw everything into space very
cheaply and so forth yeah
sure i could see us never having to
build a ground-based telescope ever
again forget the starling problem we're
good to go
well guess what you can't do that it's
very expensive and not only that
uh they're it's very complex right
ground-based telescopes
are easier they're accessible you can go
and fix them very easily you can upgrade
them very easily
and that's why we got telescopes that
have been like the
you know the i mentioned earlier the uh
the zwicky transit facility this
the survey uh instrument that has
caught you know it has discovered
planetesimals in the outer
uh uh ort cloud
far kuiper belt guess what it's mounted
to the 48-inch
mid telescope that was built in the
1930s
you know it's an upgrade to an old
telescope and it works
awesome it is freaking amazing so yeah i
mean
again there's you know what problem do
you want to solve you know exactly
that and rokia rookie says i'm on my
channel or we can meet halfway and fly
an infrared telescope in a 747. funny
you should ask that question
hint for a future live stream um
yes we do have the sofia observatory
that is uh
doing some infrared uh work
aboard a modified 747
um there's a question here let's go
ahead and uh
and and hop hop over hop around a little
bit first of all
nicholas paulson thank you very very
much for the super chat
really do appreciate that any news on
future plans for arecibo
since the live stream with dr menendez
yes nicholas there will be a follow-up
live stream i've been in touch with him
i'm afraid i cannot say
anything else at this time except
we got a show coming and i think you're
gonna like it
all right uh and uh let's see
uh so uh zosk was asking why is planet
nine so important isn't there a
possibility there is more than two
planets medium size far off pluto
uh brian you want to take that one since
you talked to constant
constantine more recently than i have
yeah there's millions of objects the
question is you know what
what constitutes a planet and you know
why are these
objects so important uh i think you know
what's fascinating to me
about these objects is again
understanding you know the the
cosmic chicken or egg questions are
always fascinating to me you know which
came first
the solar system or or the or the debris
or the planets
uh which came first the universe or the
multiverse
which came first the chicken or the egg
or the dna i did a video
this week about you know kind of does
life create chirality or does chirality
because you know christian as your
listeners are some of the most astute in
the
known universe as our mind that um all
life is predicated on right-handed helix
style dna whereas most all elementary
particles neutrinos are all left-handed
we call left-handed neutrinos
and some have speculated that that
there's some link between those
and it's basically chicken or egg type
type postulates
i uh feel that way about the solar
system and to learn more about the solar
you know did the solar system form
you know the planets form first or the
solar system form first and a sort of
more
uh coarse-grained uh perspective and
then of course are there other
kuiper belts are there other objects uh
could they be responsible for
you know what my past guest avi loeb
claimed was an extraterrestrial piece of
kit
uh namely umua or is that just like
kuiper belt objects there's a lot of
of controversy about that so i think
understanding it more from as many
diverse perspectives
spectrum intensity uh understanding its
orbit
and searching for it uh with as many
different you know panoptic
capabilities and that will inform us
better than almost
anyone could do alone and now you have
to add to that theoretical investigation
and modeling and simulation as i said
you know solving the three-body problem
is thought to be impossible
in classical mechanics constantine is
working on like the 20 million
uh body problem and he's uh he's really
amazing so
look look for those uh conversations to
heat up
he he is one uh intensely smart dude
and uh you know i think he's got the
best shot at
uh getting us there uh let's see did you
have another question on your end that
you wanted to bring up ryan
i know uh no i only take one from yours
okay uh so uh well i think this well
actually dennis uh
polyakov uh pointed out right now i
think less than five percent of
scientific
applications pass the approving board
and get telescope time
and then he goes on to add that he was
referring to the hubble space telescope
yeah uh you're right hubble is very over
subscribed again for a
old you know obsolete obsolete telescope
it's the one that people want to use
more than anything else right now you
know and um
but oh yeah and i guess i guess i should
also just mention
we talked about this in the comments
before but just so everybody knows
hubble is officially not yet back in
business but we expect it to be back in
business back on sky
is we call it you know doing science
could be as early as the end of the
end of this weekend uh some wonderful
news a great development they've
actually
uh you know flipped over to the opposite
side
of the electronics on the payload
computer and i did make a video about it
where i went to some of the gory
engineering details because i
i can't help myself i just nerd out on
stuff like that
but uh you know they're in the best
hands over there
uh with hst i mean they've got they've
got some serious uh
brain power uh we also have a big hello
from south wales hey
biker boy one hello from south wales
good to see whales in the house how you
doing
okay let me uh let me just double check
see if there's any other questions here
i think oh and johnny was asking uh can
data from the gaia mission be used in
search for planet nine
uh brian do you have any uh knowledge of
that um
you know guys astrometric looking for
parallax
measurements it did collect you know a
billion
images of stars uh it would be hard to
believe that there's nothing
lurking in there on the other hand you
know space is quite large and
we have this image from the you know
console video game
asteroids that i wasted uh probably you
know
a thousand quarters on or more in my
youth uh
that you know it's kind of like just
rotten it's like a junkyard and you're
trying to get through it and
people are shooting you know shotguns at
you
it's not really like that uh especially
once you get out of the plane of the
solar system where most of the
guy observations in the plane of the
galaxy is where most of the observations
take place which isn't aligned
with the zodiacal band so um
it could be it could be that that that
it is lurking in there but
um but you know it's certainly there's
so much richness in that data set from
the dynamics of stars
celestial mechanics orbiting um but you
know way back when it was thought that
you could actually have
dark matter be caused you know the
actual responsible
entity for dark matter not some exotic
medium like an axion that i've talked
about with frank wilchuk on the channel
or modified newtonian dynamic but it
could just be macho's massive
complex halo objects which was contra
distinction to wimps
which are somewhat falling out of favor
in some spaces
this wimp miracle may turn out to be a
wimp nightmare
but anyway we we really have kind of
lost the
uh lost the the hope that these machos
could really play a role as a dominant
form of dark matter
and yet we know they're there and these
could be basically objects around other
stars that are like their kuiper belts
or their org clouds or whatever
so yeah there could be stuff in gaia for
sure i'm not
entirely familiar with it but i think it
is uh it is uh
it is a promising thing to look for
absolutely yeah
i would agree um i mean you are going to
get
you should expect there to be some
astromech results the question then is
uh you know how sensitive is gaia you
know we're probably
are looking at something that is going
to be the brightest in the infrared part
of the spectrum gaia
is mainly an optical uh instrument but
if it's got an optical signature of any
kind there's a chance
you know that maybe there is a little
tiny bit of noise in the guy data
waiting to be teased out
we also have a we also have hello from
australia good morning
to you in australia where as i
understand it you are
in the future so please tell us how the
rest of my
friday evening is going to go what's the
lottery what are you talking about get
the lottery oh yeah what yeah what's the
lottery man help us out
okay good to see you uh we have um
uh so would any of you be surprised
johnny jesus is asking wouldn't you be
surprised if planet nine turns out to be
a primordial black hole
um yes personally i would be very
surprised
which is not to say that i don't think
that these things
cannot exist or ever could exist i would
just be surprised that they were so
ubiquitous that we even happen to have
one
that's my that's my hot take on it uh
brian how about yourself
yeah i i agree there's very little
evidence
it's hard to falsify because anything
gravitationally bound can mimic the
or gravitationally you know massive can
mimic the effects of a of an ordinary
material
body like a small icy rock but there's
an indeed um edwin none other than the
you know kind of uh smartest man uh
believed to be alive in some circles
he commented on this about a year or two
ago that you know planet nine you could
actually detect that planet nine is a
black hole
um by sending out a small spacecraft
near the speed of light
and then uh setting out a companion you
know millisecond later
or you know basically two spacecraft
sending time-delayed signals and you
could look for
shapiro delay other types of phenomenon
general relativity that would be
indicative of
a truly point-like or you know
singularity type
um entity rather than just a massive
distributed body like a small planet
so uh those are those are you know
people think about those things for sure
that is an interesting avenue to pursue
yeah uh that that's that sounds like a
very cool experiment and something i've
never considered but then again
it takes a century though it takes a
century yeah it does
well there's actually a good reason why
i haven't considered it because i'm not
smart like ed wouldn't you know that's
that's the thing
the guy is the guy is super super clever
uh let's see oh and videographer
experience points out and this was a
reference to our conversation about
hubble two space telescopes mean double
the observing time
uh yeah actually uh that's a really good
point uh videographer because
uh one of the key things i mean this is
yeah you know hubble
a couple's old it means 31 years old
that we may
no one has a crystal ball but we're
thinking we're kind of hoping now with
this switch the electronics will be good
for another
maybe five years or so yeah maybe longer
you know
and so the hope the real hope is that
there will be uh
some overlapping observations between
webb
and hubble keep in mind hubble's
primarily optical web
is infrared and it'll be great to aim
both
both barrels at you know at a target and
get that kind of uh panchromatic
coverage uh so that would be
super cool we we hope you know yeah um
yeah that's uh you know i think it's i
think it's entirely
uh likely we will see that at least for
a little while
uh and then uh there's a paper but
planet nine is really getting is
is the sexy topic you know brian i don't
know why you and i are here today we
should have just constantine get on both
of our channels and
go we could have we could have had an
early dinner but anyway
uh there's a paper from last year that
claims that planet nine is just an
observation
bias spending more telescope time
looking at the detection where we
assumed those objects would be
yeah there's that and
i don't want to get into he said he said
or whatever but you know
yeah there's a paper that came out and
then there's people like
mike brown and constantine who say no
that's it's not an observation bias
i don't know that that's above my pay
grade so
i know if you have any thoughts or not
yeah no no i think that's a good that's
accurate
as from my perspective too so brian what
do you got do you have anything on your
own
uh yes that's right uh
so yeah we're getting uh getting another
question
about um yeah about using the
using the solar system objects like the
moon
as a base for future observational uh
technologies in particular in my field
joe silk who's a pioneer
titan in the field of primordial
perturbation theory
i work with stephen hawking as the
father of so-called silk damping he's a
cosmologist now at johns hopkins
he has an idea for a radio low frequency
radio telescope on the moon
and the dark side of the moon because of
radio interference not from
you know one web and spacex and stuff
but from
uh you know from garage door openers
from whistlers in the atmosphere from am
radio ham radio
and uh there on the back side of the
moon it's very stable
it's very dark radio dark shielded by
you know
11 000 kilometers of lunar dirt
so i think that could be a promising
place for a telescope
for other things like ligo or
gravitational wave observatories you
know the moon has moon quakes it has
some kind of not tectonic activity
because we don't believe it has such
such plates but nevertheless it has it
has an active moonquake type surface
it has micrometeorites raining down on
it big meteors raining down on it
it's not the ideal place that people
think and actually even the
lunar circular collider in some parts
you know the two you know would go over
like between mountain ranges on the moon
and it would
have to like send the beam through a
through a tunnel that would be suspended
over a valley on the moon like this and
and uh so actually beach oh the vacuum
is pretty good on the moon's surface so
just shoot the particles you know across
the across the chasm there
and they'll bridge the gap just fine as
long as it's not you know the curvature
is not too great you're not trying to go
too far so actually having an open
tube particle accelerator really reduces
the cost
because a lot of the cost of the lhc is
you know building the vacuum um
the magnets etc are very expensive and
super conducting them but actually the
moon part of the moon would be really
cold
so yeah telescopes on the moon other
places in the solar system are less
uh saying i'm less sanguine about but
yeah i think i think they're
uh there are prospects um so christian
we're coming up on the end
i am going to go and dip in the pacific
ocean
i know you are going to go into the
atlantic ocean uh
soon and i do want to ask you the
thrilling three questions that are
patented on my channel where as i say i
talk to
nine nobel laureates i have a book
coming out did i tell you my second book
is coming out christian
no i didn't know that brad yeah i've got
a new book it's called the
into the impossible think like a nobel
prize winner i took all nine
interviews with the nobel laureates and
i put it uh i put them together edited
the conversation distilled their wisdom
into
actionable actionable advice of their
habits their tactics their tricks and
traps
and actually got barry barrish
co-recipient of the 2017 nobel prize
to write the forward and he kind of
inspired me to write the book and put it
into
into print i hope this will be a
continuing series as i get more and more
nobel prize winners to come on the show
but anyway i asked them all this que
these questions and i'm going to ask
them to you because you are in this
portion my guest
and the first question involves the near
future for yourself
personally so there's tradition that uh
a
righteous person lives to 120 years old
so
when you get there you're about a third
of the way there probably maybe a
quarter of the way there i don't know
how old you are
but you're going to get there 120 when
you get there what piece of ethical
wisdom do you want to leave
for future generations to adhere to
um be kind
i i know that sounds trite but um you
know
we all are human and we are all going to
have our bad days and we're all going to
get frustrated and so forth but
sometimes you got to work a little bit
at it you got to think a little bit
before you speak you got to think a lot
before you send that email especially
before you hit that
twit tweet button um you know
look we're living in an age where
instant communication
and fighting is it's never been easier
to fight with somebody
and we're seeing we we are seeing
the consequences of i don't have to tell
you what they are
it works everything from contesting
elections
to losing faith in democracy to
you know you know
accelerating our own extinction you know
um we we got to get out of that and if
we could just practice a little bit more
kindness i know it sounds kind of
trite but like i said if we could
practice a lot more kindness we'll do
that and i'm inspired of course by
you know mickey heart of the grateful
dead over here who at the end of the
fare thee well
concert said please be kind and that
always resonated with me
yeah and stay curious he said that i
think too
yeah um uh next question involves the
deep future
of the universe and it hearkens to 2001
a space odyssey
based on the book by sir arthur c clarke
which is the namesake of the center that
i co-direct at uc san diego the arthur
clark center for human imagination
where i'm the co-director he said or he
had in the sentinel these
kind of ominous uh we don't really know
what they were these are obelisks
monoliths etc
i like to think of them as time capsules
meant to be discovered when the
discoverer has reached the
intellectual and cognitive maturity
necessary to decode
what is embedded within them on them of
them i want to ask you christian
feynman said that the most dense in
terms of information
the most dense sentence is the atomic
hypothesis that everything is made of
atoms
and atoms are made of quantum mechanical
elementary particles
let me ask you what sentence what
knowledge what learnings in astronomy
have you gleaned
that you think represent the pinnacle of
human civilization
wow uh i that is a
very profound question and as you were
asking it an answer immediately came to
my mind
but i actually don't think it's a direct
quote
okay but i'm gonna go ahead and use it
anyway because it's attributed to carl
sagan who said
somewhere something incredible is
waiting to be discovered
and what does that have to do with human
civilization it
it means that there's you know no matter
what level of of of greatness or
self-aggrandizement we may we may reach
there's still something incredible
waiting to be discovered there's still
something more we need to reach for
there's still it's a reminder
that we still don't know as much as we
think we do
that there's carl there's the carl
finger puppet right there yes
yep you gotta bring him out i had on his
widow and his daughter
have been on my show yeah this guy folks
watch his channel he
he gets the coolest people on here you
know but again you know that that quote
is something that's also
resonated with me because yeah no matter
how much we think we know
we need to keep reaching and if there's
anything
that i would love for somebody to find
in our monolith
would be something along that quote
something that described
that no matter who these people were or
how great they thought they could be
they
still were curious they still stayed
ever curious and i think that
is probably the best thing about being
in the universe we are a way for the
universe to know itself once again to
invoke
uh carl sagan yeah exactly and the final
question
involves going backwards in time and
actually the name of this podcast of my
side of the podcast into the impossible
and it's based on sir arthur's famous
laws uh one of which is for every expert
there's an equal and opposite expert my
wife
trots that out on numerous occasions
another law
is that any sufficiently advanced
technology
is indistinguishable from magic and the
third one is the only way of discovering
the limits of the possible
is to venture beyond them into the
impossible and that's the name of my
podcast
i want to ask you as a young fellow if
you could
travel back in time via wormhole via
black hole some other kind of hole
if you could do something like that
would you what advice would you give to
the 20 year old version of yourself
advice
to your former self please
hang in there man um
you know i've been through uh i i
i left the field for a while went into
tech
you know got fired from every job i i
ever had and outside of astronomy and
came back into my field
no i i guess the thing is it's like
that that that's that's a
tongue-in-cheek here's the thing
here's the thing i i would say to myself
hang in there
it gets so much better you have you know
no idea and just believe in yourself
and i think that we can take
that advice to fault people think
sometimes they're greater than what they
are and i'm not suggesting that we say
that i would tell
i would tell 20 year old chris i would
say hey
just believe you're going to make it
you're going
there are great things ahead for you
hang in there and stay curious and
you'll be all right
and i like to think by virtue of the
fact that i'm not
not all right then i must be all right
very very nice well it's been a thrill
to do this crisscross
applesauce crossover and congratulations
and mazel tov
on your 100 000 subscriber primary
mirror
can you show us that can you can you
just give me the glimpse of it i'll i'll
never get it so
uh oh yes you will want to go
not at this rate this rate is like
slower than the expansion of the
universe but
oh come on all right uh so
folks i'm sorry i this is i feel kind of
weird wow
look at that it looks like you pointed
at me then i'll be i'll finally be able
to look at myself in a
in a shiny youtube so now you can see
what i see
if you look at my mirror but anyway i'm
i'm uh
i'm very grateful and i gotta admit i
gotta admit when uh
when well thank you brian i i have to
admit when i when i uh
when i got this the very first thing
that uh
came to my mind was my mom i know that
she was the biggest cheerleader
and she would have been so proud of that
she would be more excited about this
than than i was
actually and uh and that's not an
exaggeration so
um but yeah you know i knew you when i
knew you when you had 56
000 subscribers uh about a year or two
ago you were gracious enough to have me
on for some reason that uh
i will never be able to repay you and i
do want to thank you so much
and encourage my viewers to subscribe to
christian get them to two hundred
thousand get them to a million
get them and beyond into the impossible
and and folks check out dr brian keating
check out his youtube channel it is
wonderful you will hear just one
amazing mind-blowing conversation with a
true intellectual
accepting today's talk but you'll be so
surprised at the folks that he gets on a
show on a
regular basis you know why because he's
damn smart folks he is
absolutely well earned and you know what
he's a year from now we're going to be
celebrating
his actually screw at the end of this
year we're going to be celebrating his
silver plate
and i'm making me blush look i'm
blushing i know it you're making me
blush
and uh show me how to do it subscribe to
the
into the impossible podcast oh thanks
everybody it's so cool to
see this it's an honor have a great
weekend everybody raise a pint to chris
and uh wherever you are remember my
motto is stay curious my friend and
chris what's your motto
oh uh maybe abc always be curious yeah
right
we're we're trading mottos today so yeah
you know i know we haven't talked about
virgin galactic and blue origin sorry
it's an hour show what are we gonna do
but we will we will be back and we'll
have some more
uh because of that and yes uk man says i
subbed because you explained
physics clearly that's to you brian
nicely done oh very nice thank you guys
thank you so much christian
have a great weekend i'll talk to you
all later bye everybody thank you my
friend and i'll just and i know brian
has a heart
has a heart